tastebuddy's the first ever taste buds
live stream is upon us May 10th 9 p.m
Eastern Standard time we are coming to
you live from the taste bud no press
Studios with special guests special
surprises and an epic battle that will
be unrivaled
it's 10 bucks it's super cheap you watch
it live and then you have a week to
watch it on video on demand uh and you
can finally vote live you vote live in
real time so check it out and we'll see
you May 10th go to moment dot Co slash
taste buds we want to see you there
folks Joe DeRosa here I got some live
dates a few dates to throw at you you
know how it goes I Never Promised You a
Rose Garden where and when New York City
May 3rd that's this week at the crane
theater that's the last of the residency
run there at least for now uh May 4th
and 5th Pittsburgh that's also this week
doing I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
out there and then into September
because I'm taking the summer off Avenal
New Jersey the Avenal Performing Arts
Center September 16th that's a Saturday
all tickets and showtimes available at
joederrosa.com that's right I got my own
name.com now nothing's got Gonna Stop Me
Joey roses also come through we're open
seven days a week at 11 30 every day
sandwiches good times and booze joyrus
nyc.com what's up taste buddies I am on
the road with the Impractical Jokers we
are halfway through the tour adding
dates all the time so check out
impracticaljokerslive.com uh coming up
next May 5th and 6th we are in West
Valley City Utah and Denver Colorado May
19 20 and 21 Arlington Texas The Moody
Center in Austin and Sugarland Texas
June 2nd 3rd and 4th Columbus Ohio
Cleveland Ohio and Detroit at the fox
June 15 16 17 Minneapolis Des Moines and
Kansas City and then rounding out the
last posted dates right now in July
we're coming to Nashville to play the
Grand Ole Opry House uh the Cambridge
Field House in Indianapolis and two at
the stifle theater in St Louis
everything available at
impracticaljokerslive.com
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight only one food can be right taste
buds man yeah they're coming to the mic
I'm talking how you taste buddies
welcome to t-a-s-t-e Buds and we have
Joe De Rosa back with us this week it's
good to be back how did last week go
with Jay Larson I refuse to watch when
I'm not on the program I understand that
you're a curmudgeon that's what you do
that's okay it's it's a man protecting
his worth his self-esteem oh it's a man
not supporting his own business somebody
else would be honest it's a little
something I have with Jay Larson wow Jay
was actually great I know I'm joking I
love you I know I know I know I know
you're joking [__] man oh I said the f
all right we didn't mean to Jay thank
you Jay for filling in uh Jay's actually
with us this weekend in Bangor Maine and
Boston he's opening for us this weekend
oh that's nice yeah that's nice you are
also with us you're not you're not yeah
I keep telling you don't say it it's a
fun it's a fun surprise okay well the
people in the audience who bought
tickets are the ones who have had to see
this huh and they don't know when you're
gonna be with us so here look I want to
thank someone who made these beautiful
mug thrush no pressure mugs hey babe and
taste buds really cool
um I've had them for a while I forgot
who they came from but you know who you
are and thank you very much we have a
couple of these so wait a minute you
just said to me you've had those in your
home yeah they were in plastic wrapping
like when I got them I threw them in the
closet and I realized where'd you get
them from like five or six times I meant
to bring them someone gave them to me at
some point like oh someone handed them
too I think so yeah oh Oh I thought you
were saying you took them out of this
office brought them to your home in a
selfish no maneuver no that's you're all
over the place I'm not all over the
place I'm right here I'm right here
right here uh today's battle is gonna be
oh wait I gotta weigh on the Larson
battle weigh in yeah uh Larson what do
we have there let me guess crabs versus
Feasts
Boston versus the Celtics versus the
Eagles no it was actually Lucky Charms
versus Cinnamon Toast Crunch wow two
cereals I wouldn't shake a stick at wow
you're in the minor
I said it before I'll say it again
Cinnamon Toast Crunch is the red-headed
stepchild of Golden Grahams Golden
Grahams destroy Cinnamon Toast Crunch
it's not even close I hate cinnamon
toast crunch it tastes like rice it
tastes like if you just sprinkled
cinnamon on Rice Krispies to me I think
it sucks and I mean I would tell you I
only tried it once and for the first
time over the over the pan D and uh I I
get it I get why people like it uh I
didn't realize how how many people are
like stands
of it
stands what's that mean I mean like the
like Eminem Stan like big major fans
yeah is that what you meant what did you
say Eminem stands the Eminem song Stand
about like the obsessed fan are you
saying people are stands of cinnamon
chocolate covered candy
what the hell is stand that's actually I
actually that is I think where it comes
from it is that is the origin of it yeah
it's insane that you piece that together
well what the hell else could it be it's
a crazy thing to say yeah I thought it
was like shortened before I stand with
that first but this is where it's from
uh anyway
um right I and then and then Lucky
Charms is you know that that elf can go
screw what is he a guy what's his name
we pulled up his photos he changed over
the years and a new one looks like a
sociopath what's he look oh look at that
Jesus that's demonic oh my God wait
scroll up pimp wait wait look at that
one The Unlucky Charms what's that was
that a real box that can't be real I
think it was it was a limited that can't
be real
yeah oh oh full moon horror full moon
horror makes oh it's a DVD oh that's
great they made a movie called Unlucky
Charms oh God man that would have been
great if that was it is it's a
collector's cereal box and full moon
Heart full moon horror Studios made uh
you know they made puppet the Puppet
Master movies
they've made a lot of I saw leprechaun
recently leprechaun was not made by full
moon but I own
every leprechaun film ever made
one of them I have Leprechaun in the
Hood I own that one
that's rough stuff speaking of Banger
Banger Main
tonight tonight at Bangor Maine Cross
Insurance Center month oh no sorry it
was this Thursday yeah yeah my bad what
are you doing
and thanks for coming out
uh so so I wouldn't I mean it's Lucky
Charms is a [__] cereal it's it without
those marshmallows you got nothing you
know you know babe we we covered this
pimp asked me to weigh in I'm weighing
in yeah well look the marshmallows are
the key ingredients and a key ingredient
is something about the marshmallow and
the the sugar coat covered oat that oat
sugar covered that don't ain't sugar oh
well something about the two together
that was really nice yes but I will say
this a key ingredient to me is not you
could the carrot doesn't carry the whole
dish you could have a box of Lucky a
bowl of Lucky Charms in front of your
fresh Bowl just before it's still
crunchy with a spoon right in front of
it you could resist that
I'd take a bite
Honestly though Cinnamon Toast Crunch I
would have zero I think Lucky Charms
would be harder for me to resist zero
but I gotta tell you though my I want to
just I want to really drive this point
home over the plate
a king from now on when you drive a a
point over a plate when you're gonna do
that let's just bring it because the
police so when you feel like you're had
you hammered home a point finish it with
Cordoba boom okay I like it all right I
say it in my life and I don't say it on
the podcast all right fair enough yeah I
think a key ingredient to me a key
ingredient is more like along the lines
of like
if I made you a cake
like if I made you a wonderful apple
cake right and then you said what's an
apple cake no Sal come on you know what
some of the [__] you don't know of is
astounding to me what is an apple you
never had apples I know I was thinking
too about a thing or two and what you
don't know can fill up a book please
what you know if you never had apple
cake so it's cake that tastes like apple
dude it's amazing you would love I mean
I've never even seen it on the menu for
real it's not usually on menus it's
usually something a Nana or a loving
mother makes oh I guess there's your
answer but but apple cake is great but
here's my point let's all right let's
say I made you a wonderful apple pie
sure
and you said Joe I gotta tell you key
ingredient in this thing or like what
puts your apple pie over the top versus
the other that dash of cinnamon that I'm
tasting more but that to me is key
ingredient key ingredient is not one of
the two ingredients
come on you you're saying
the two things both things in Lucky
Charms are the key ingredient you don't
have it without the other one I don't
even know what we're doing I argued with
Jay about this I'm saying you remove I
lost one of those you took Cinnamon
Toast Crunch no oh you took Lucky Charms
yeah eat Lucky Charms I'm saying you
take one of those ingredients you take
those ingredients you separate them you
got a bowl of marshmallows that are
edible and tasty and a bowl of dog [__]
like that's it like there's there's yeah
but you could with the two together is
what makes Lucky Charms I understand
that but I'm sorry I can't just eat a
bowl of marshmallows even though I like
them I can't it's too much my my point
is it's like saying it's like saying
this toast the key ingredient in this
toast is the strawberry jam on it it's
like that toast ain't doing a goddamn
thing by itself it's not doing anything
it's it's lifting nothing yeah it's
lifting nothing Lucky Charms is lit for
an hour all right all right fine fair
enough nice to have you our battle today
good to see you again halfway I sent you
a picture apple of of a carrot cake last
night yeah you saw let's just clear the
air here we battle carrot cake versus
cheese what would you would you have
chocolate cake I think no
he was opposed to carrot cake a few
weeks back a couple months back this man
has been traipsing all over New York
City the greater metropolitan area yes
ordering cheesecake at every
establishment I'm sorry it's a carrot
cake and every establishment he walks
into who won that
crumb cake I believe one yeah so you
were against it and you beat it and now
he sends me a picture of him eating the
carrot cake once a week it's not it's
ridiculous I have been I have been in
recent weeks
frequenting some I wouldn't say fine
restaurants but some nicer places will
you sit down for a meal last night I
went to Keen Steakhouse it's a wonderful
place if you've never been uh a couple
weeks ago I went to a museum to to to to
to look at the hip-hop exhibit and then
I went into the restaurant downstairs
Museum in Union Square I was with Paul
Italia
and speaking of Paul next week's guest
just a little teaser for the hip-hop
heads out there is legendary producer
and Hip-Hop head and Aficionado uh who's
behind day lost soul yes and
gravediggers and Sonic modeling school
Prince Paul is Going to Be Our Guest
next week we are ecstatic so far all you
out there that means something too we
know how excited you are as well I can't
believe he's I he is in the top 10 of
all-time hip-hop producers well we will
talk to them about it yeah anyway so
um but the night of the hip-hop exhibit
we went to the restaurant inside that
museum in Union Square forget the
Museum's day and we were getting dessert
after we had this tremendous meal we had
steak we had uh we had wienerschnitz not
Wienerschnitzel I'm sorry um schnitzel
with the breaded yeah that's so funny I
remember when I found out what schnitzel
was it's a breaded chicken call it so
good that's what it is yeah
and at at dessert we all wanted to get
dessert and we said to the waiter what
or waitress what do you think what is
the move here and she goes you got to
get the carrot cake and I was like I
don't know man I'm like and she was like
you guys gotta get this we got three
desserts we're like well I'll share I
hit that carrot cake I was like holy
[__] man your eyes were little shreds of
real carrot in it also the Magnolia
carrot cake cupcakes put me over the top
are they still good do you think no oh
she's so excited I just got it's been
two months plus maybe more I don't know
okay months way more all right uh uh I
will gladly participate in getting that
box and seeing you take a bite
they might still be good maybe there's
there's you know there's like I'm not no
sweets today okay because I had sweets
last night anyway after dinner last
night I'm looking at the dessert menu
you draw the line it says it says our
family's carrot cake that's how it reads
on the menu at Keane's Chop House they
know what to do
waiter came over I go tell me about the
carrot cake he goes
man you got I was like bring it he
brought it and it did not disappoint and
I loved sending you that picture
do you know that I made a oh you were at
the house knowing you uh no you weren't
at the house when I made a carrot cake
from scratch no
of course I'd be talking I recently made
a carrot cake from scratch that's what
made that's what made you argue it
that's why we that's right I mean I feel
the carrots everything from you yeah and
it was it was just fantastic you made
your own cream cheese icing I did wow
to make me a carrot cake this year for
my birthday
challenge me all you do is give me a
test to make you a cake you can't do
that for your buddy absolutely will I
want you to was it August August 6th 6th
whatever drunken scenario we end up in
on that day or the days around it I want
you to bring a homemade from scratch
character okay you got it and we will
all eat it together in whatever bar
we're in okay all right uh
is it too much
thank you
this guy now
but he
my PR every day is a gift with me
uh all right our battle today we got to
get to it our battle today is milkshakes
versus
root beer floats
Sal you our team root beer floats and I
am team
milkshake we didn't do this right I
never argued a root beer float I feel
like I did and I feel like it was at
your bar was it part of a lightning
round
did you do a search and did you do a
search
that's too late now oh well it's all
right if as long as it wasn't up against
milkshake
I'm not sure okay we're good it's fine
all right so let's just get into this
battle because I got a lot to say yeah
ready yeah time two be
I can't believe you have the sack
to think a root beer float it's gonna
take down the all-encompassing menu item
of Milkshakes it's just nuts first of
all a root beer float hasn't been on a
menu since 1954 when Fonzi correct I
just went to
um Burns Steakhouse in Tampa which is a
legendary Steakhouse well as far as
steakhouses in Tampa go I hear that's
one of the best no no that's that's what
I thought this place is home to Kings
and Queens this place Burns you got
Outback no no I'm telling you you don't
know what you're talking about dude it's
like a seven-year-old Steakhouse it's
inside of it it's like five five things
on the Block that they added together
it's this long crazy weird building and
and inside one room's decorated like a
goddamn medieval castle but it burns I'm
hanging out with Steve Byrne later yeah
he's recording the answer to record but
I gotta run home yes uh my point I've
already done this they have and I think
I might have mentioned this to you but
they have a when you're done eating in
one of the rooms that you're in there's
an upstairs separate full room slash
restaurant of its own that just deals
with desserts wow and they have like a
hundred desserts wait and they Usher you
from your seat and they take you
upstairs now upstairs is all dark right
dimly lit and there people eat in these
little private
wooden barrel coves that are all over
the floor so you walk and then you go
you look into like this little like wood
slatted thing right maybe you could pull
it up Bern's Steakhouse in Tampa uh the
dessert room and you sit down and you're
in your own pod like a wooden pod that's
made to look like barrels and so you
don't see anybody right else and you
have your menu your group in there
there's five buttons on the wall and you
can push each button and each button has
a different type of music playing from
like old-timey Jazz to whatever and
there's also a phone okay and if you
pick up the phone
and someone else picks up the phone
it'll connect you to their barrel and
you could talk to someone you don't know
on the phone it's dude I never seen
anything like it in my life rubia float
was on the menu and if that was good
enough for them it's good enough for
your boy yeah okay yeah yeah you found
yeah root beer float was on the menu of
the Wonka Factory
with Goofy
is that goofy
it was an all-time dining experience so
you call it what you want it sounds it
sounds awesome but literally we just
just described sounds like if you were
like if you're like I'll tell you where
there's a root beer floating menu
there's a swingers club
in Poughkeepsie you go into an attic you
have to use the code word of course you
throw your keys in the bowl and they've
got a root beer float yeah uh you're
you're in a you're in a real narrow
you're dealing with a place there's a
hundred milk desserts yeah I look
milkshake is like the days of like the
old-timey Diner right I get it I'll tell
you this milkshake I'll tell you this
the only place I've ever seen milkshake
anymore is ready ready ready for it
Diner and
and McDonald's make some mean milkshake
when the machine's working by the way
May 10th Wednesday night just to divert
for one second is the first we got it
May 10th Wednesday night pimp is uh
gonna put the link if you're watching a
YouTube video uh the links below us or
you can click on it in the body of below
the video if you're watching online go
to moments just go to moments as a
search moment
m-o-m-e-n-t dot Co and look up taste
buds it's slash taste buds it's
Wednesday night May 10th tickets went on
sale a couple of days ago this is the
first time we're announcing the ticket
sales directly on this podcast we just
put it up on socials so this is the call
to action for every listener and viewer
right now May 10th Wednesday evening 9
p.m we're streaming live we are
foregoing a live audience stream we're
not going to do it at a live audience
venue we were at first and it proved
difficult so we're doing it here in
studio big surprises
big guest surprises and what I think the
biggest battle we've ever had it's it's
a super sized show it's like 10 bucks
you get to watch uh along live and for
the first time ever which people have
been asked us for two and a half years
you're gonna get to vote in real time uh
which never happens and so they could
basically use our argument
without giving away too much there will
be
a McDonald's element
without getting away too much one of the
surprises is the McDonald's elements you
can take that which you will if you're
an avid fan you might be able to make a
couple guesses if not I don't know uh
but yeah we'll join us we'll have a
handful of guests
join us you get to watch so it's on VOD
it's on video on demand as well up to
seven days after you purchase it it's uh
10 bucks now like 12 bucks a day of but
it's it it shouldn't be missed I think
it'll be our most special episode today
I agree so if you're a fan and you know
a fan tell a fan we'll see you that
night we're planning it now it's
ridiculous I agree folks let's talk
about better help this show is sponsored
by better help better help's a great
service I use it I love it it has helped
me greatly in navigating this crazy
experience we call Life uh it can throw
a lot of curveballs at you it can be
quite challenging at times and it
doesn't come with a rule book and I find
the therapy I received through better
help to be extremely convenient and
extremely helpful I love it and think
about how much time you spend on
yourself in a week and how much time you
spend on others you know I think you
should take time for yourself and not a
lot of people do that and betterhelp is
a good way to do that learn yourself you
know therapy can give you the tools to
find more balance in your life is you
can keep supporting others without
leaving yourself behind if you're
thinking to start in therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire and get match with a
licensed therapist and you could switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge find more balance with better
help visit
betterhelp.com tastebuds today you're
going to get 10 off your first month
that's better h-e-l-p better help
h-e-l-p.com taste buds
you know one of my favorite things about
getting a box of Awesome from bespoke
Posts every month is how it sneaks up on
you I forget I have it it's a
subscription service and it's worth more
than I pay for it and it comes and they
kind of curate things to my liking you
forget that it's coming and one day boom
it's at your front door it is fun and
you're like let's see what you got this
one it is no matter what you have going
on the spring box of awesome as you
covered from camping gear Essentials
cookout must-haves and drink game
upgrades their collections for every
part of your life to get started take
the quiz at box of awesome.com and your
answers help them pick the right stuff
for you they release new boxes every
single month across a ton of different
categories and each box is valued at
about 70 bucks but you only pay a
fraction of that price plus each box of
awesome you're supporting small
businesses because ninety percent of
everything that comes in a box of
awesome is from a small and upcoming
brand it's free to sign up and you can
skip a month or cancel anytime it's fun
it's a no-brainer get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com and enter code tastebuds at
checkout that's box of awesome.com code
taste buds for twenty percent off your
first box box of awesome.com code taste
buds done spielen about the [__] live
stream can we get back to the battle
yeah yeah you're done yeah all right so
milkshake maybe focus a little bit I
love I I love them but I will tell you I
have the milkshake on that I'm breaking
your balls I thought you'd break my I'm
trying to get to this battle
all right so with the milkshake
it's so delicious when it hits your lips
and then like anything you keep sucking
on it eventually just goes south uh it
no it's so delicious but when you're
done with a milkshake you're every time
I have added Milkshake the first simple
the first half of it I'm like oh this is
like this Jesus must have made this the
recipe at least and passed it along to
his disciples but then by the end of it
I'm like bloated and full and there's
too much heavy cream in me and I'm just
like uh I am I drank too much of that
damn milkshake and it's always a bad
ending it's the distance that's your
fault if this man's never good with the
milkshake that's your fault that's not
the milkshake if you get this milkshake
mouth after if you don't understand no
you got this milk this milk never got
that milkshake mouth that you need to go
brush your teeth otherwise you have this
like soury milkshake mouth via saying
yes that's not true okay
is that a milkshake I won't be a float
not as common
you do I do she does you did something
wrong with you people get it Joe please
you don't have ice if you have ice cream
you don't get that you need something to
break it up no I love a glass of water
after a bowl of ice cream it's very
refreshing but that's not because I have
ice cream mouth it just tastes good I'm
telling you people you get that like
that Dairy milkshake and you you don't
get this from a root beer float no
because the root beer cuts through the
sugar from that root beer and those
secret ingredients in the root beer
which by the way root beer to me is the
best Cola that has ever been invented
and you combine that then with ice cream
and whipped cream and you make that
float now I from a child like milkshakes
but from a child rupia float with
something special there was an A W on
Highland Boulevard and Midland Avenue in
Staten Island that then became a diner
but a w when I was little was was the
was the tits right and we used to go
there and they they would bring out the
food and hang it on our car window the
tray and they would give you arubia
float in a big a w Frosted Mug and it
was with the the whole combination with
the cheeseburger and fries people order
a milkshake with cheeseburger and fries
I say a root beer float is even better
the milkshake
absolutely you're an idiot root beer
floats it suck let me tell you why
there's about a two second window with a
root beer float
first of all it's got vanilla ice cream
in it which sucks because now it's a
cream soda cream soda is the worst
[__] drink on planet Earth period
that's a fact my lips to God's Not cream
soda cream soda it turns it into
Creamery with ice cream uh and I will
tell you this dope the root beer float
has about a two second window where the
root beer and the ice cream are
separated and you get sort of a blend of
the two and then it turns into this
disgusting like like Le like there is
nothing broken what are you taking to
eat a root to have a drink I'm not gonna
down that's not a word
no it's not gaboon yeah yeah check
yourself maybe where you come from yeah
maybe where you shop
you remember that remember that Wayne's
World thing no when he's like oh it's
it's it's uh what do you say he goes
it's
he goes it's six it's basically six
six for ten cents and somebody goes you
mean a diamond doesn't he goes oh sorry
it's 12 for 10 cents because you mean a
diamond doesn't he goes maybe where you
shop
it gets that weird like like like spider
Webby look to it where it's like the the
ice cream is melted and it's it's
clashing with the foam and the carbon no
it's not clashing it's gross combining
to make something different there are
different stages to a root beer float
and that's what I love about it and by
the way if you have a nice fresh ice
cream scoop on top and that root beer is
cold it's in a frosted glass two seconds
that's a lot of factors Bubby that's a
lot as long as the root beer is cold
it's not going to go that fast it's not
and actually it is the process like an
avocado you have an avocado I don't even
know what that is you just made that up
no I don't no I didn't it's espresso
with a scoop of ice cream in it and the
espresso is hot and the and the vanilla
ice cream it melts a little bit into the
espresso espresso are you kidding me
every every every single coffee place
that's that's worth its salt never once
seen it once never once it's on menus at
restaurants
you've never
forgotto in your life never once seen it
once I'm sorry if I'm more culture than
you I don't know it's not even about
culture yeah I go drink an avocado put
your clam Pizza and these other things
that only exist on this island give me a
break that's it do you see it sort of
the beautiful fine dining establishment
they pour the espresso over the vanilla
ice cream staple and it's even a few
desserts I refuse to accept it and
that's how we're talking about we're
talking about a root beer before you
root beer floats suck no okay so you're
taking the worst ice cream and one of
the Lesser sodas you're taking the best
ice cream and the best [__] soda
vanilla ice cream beet chocolate ice
cream on this program and everybody was
wrong and I am right right as always now
this stage is to a root be afloat you're
acting like it's a negative when it's
not in fact it is the positive to the
rupiah float at the very another thing
you don't need is you don't have to suck
like your life depends on it to get the
first drop off
screw yes yes you have to wait you have
to wait and it's annoying as hell and
with a root beer float you get what you
do is you get the ice cream on top you
get the root beer out of the purest form
on the bottom and you go back in it it's
pure as far
you understand what I'm saying you got
yeah so you got the the cold ice cream
up top you take a scoop of that a little
whipped cream as well never hurt nobody
right come on sure though is at the
bottom of the glass so you're getting
straight up root beer so there's a
little mix there then you get to the
part where the ice cream becomes
semi-soft and it starts to get a little
more creamy and then that's a different
textural experience than initially and
then you're eating it you're eating it
and then it's probably about half your
ice cream scoop left if you know what
you're doing and then you mix it okay
and then it becomes this frothy creamy
deliciousness it's almost like when
you're a little did you ever mix
Coca-Cola and soda I mean you're gonna
be allowed to speak at any point are you
just gonna keep wrapping I'm just
talking about my portion of it right now
no no go ahead go ahead you've been
going for a while I could stop I'm just
I have something to say please stop it's
not like you're trying to get a word in
I'm speaking I'm waiting for you to come
to a [__] point that's what happens
in conversations oh boy this is your
calm conversations okay so I'll just
stop talking this is why you're home
alone while I'm out eating carrot cake
and fine restaurants you you said it
sucks I said this stages I went on to
explain myself and I was still doing
that and you said when are you gonna
stop talking if that's the vibe it's the
vibe that's the vibe all right that's
the vibe well then the vibe is fierce go
ahead can I get your fears yeah let's go
Fierce yeah let's go Kitty's Got Claws
today that's okay you want to talk
milkshakes let's talk milkshakes yeah
how dare you first of all gut Buster by
the way lactose intolerant people sorry
it's
man listen to me listen to me milkshake
strawberry chocolate vanilla peanut
butter blueberry and the list goes on
and on and on and on there is no end to
the delicious delicate decadent flavors
that you can get out of a milkshake a
milkshake will suit any any craving you
have in that moment for a sweet a
milkshake is out there that will match
that craving the milkshake float would
do that as well no that's not true you
have to want the flavor of root beer or
you have to want the flavor of ice cream
melted no but you do you hear what he
just said you have to want the flavor of
ice cream melted however wants that you
want that's what a milkshake is you what
a silly goose what a silly goose you're
a silly goose with glasses what no yeah
you have to want root beer to order a
root beer float well all I said was you
have to want a milkshake to order a
milkshake that's not a milkshake is not
the flavor of ice cream melted to me
it's a concoction made with ice cream it
becomes something much you have to want
a milkshake to order it right oh you
idiot yeah I'm saying you have one
flavor of root beer float you don't like
melted ice cream
hold on a second you have one flavor of
root beer float it's all you need it's
all you get and if you don't want the
flavor of medicinal soda medicinal
baking soda with vanilla ice cream
dumped in it then you're [__] out of
luck if you want a dessert and I said
hey guys our only option for dessert
tonight is the milkshake Place everybody
go yeah I can live with that I'll find
something at the milkshake place and the
37 flavors of Baskin and Robins and I'll
get something that works if I said the
only option for dessert tonight is the
root beer float plates they'd go yeah
I'll pass that's a silly argument I'm
not in the mood because it's not there's
not one of you though you just named
Baskin Robbins as a milkshake place
you can get a root be a float that's it
you you you're not speaking to my point
speak to my point I want you to stay on
track I want you to stay focused I am
saying if I said we have two choices for
dessert tonight okay and that's it
either I can I can only take you to a
place that serves just a variety of
Milkshakes because that's what
milkshakes are or I could take it to a
place that only as root beer floats if
the root beer float option was the only
option A lot of people would go I'll
pass on dessert whereas I think a lot of
those same people would say I'll go to
the milkshake place you can get more
granular and just say you got a
milkshake in front of you and a root
beer float in front of you which one do
you want which one am I gonna go to the
milkshake shop or am I going to the root
beer float there's a million milkshake
flavors that's one of the apps you can
get a milkshake anytime anywhere not
people don't have oh yeah because it's
so hard to make a root beer float to
dump ice cream in a soda like a pig
people don't have Roots milkshakes is
all I'm saying because they suck no it's
just because it's not on people's minds
it's not the Forefront because they suck
now things that suck aren't people you
think has been around for a hundreds of
years and you think people think it
sucks I don't think a milkshake sucks
let's be honest with each other
just because just because certain things
the ground's been around for a hundred
years it doesn't mean I want to eat it
do you think a root beer float sucks
yeah you really do I have always thought
they sucked when I was a kid I was in
awe let me let me tell you this if
somebody's been through a ruby floor
while you were sitting in a ditch you
wouldn't drink it not for not in a
second yeah not a second I'm telling you
the truth rupiah the best Cola with the
best ice cream by the way by the way you
could put that Cola by the way
by the way you could put any scoop of
ice cream you wanted there's no rule
there oh you stop you you went on and on
about flavors of Milkshakes you can't
put any flavor of ice cream in it
because a lot of flavors would Clash
with root beer flavor it's just plenty
of flavors that don't Clash is all I'm
saying you could put chocolate in it
you think chocolate would mix well with
root beer Flavor 100 million look at V's
face
it's a caramel based thing you put that
on chocolate and you can look at her
face yeah but just because V makes a
face doesn't mean make it so here's make
it so yeah make it so
I'm telling you sorry wait wait I want
to tell you something yeah tell me
when I was a child when I was a little
child this is true yeah my mother told
me she regaled me with tales of the root
beer float yeah because when she was a
child in the 40s whatever the hell was
right she was like we all had root beer
floats because that's where that drink
belongs okay
post-depression post World War II have
coming out of a people that built this
country
before where you get you gotta go you
got to work the greatest Generation
loves root be afloats what does that
tell you anyway yes the generation of
racism and sexism and and abuse child
abuse the generation that was the gears
the gears of the practice telling you
something she told me about the root
beer float so I couldn't wait I was like
there's something out there that
combined soda and ice cream I'm so in I
had one of these things I swear to God I
was like within three minutes this thing
was ruined I hated these flavors
together I hated every aspect of it and
I have tried much like the s'more to
revisit in a minute many times through
my life and every time it sucks wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute what
oh two lactose intolerant no I'm not
lactose intolerant I have a lactose
reaction but it's something that came
when I got older then well I didn't have
it as a kid oh then how are you drinking
a milkshake
I have you have told me that you pass on
stuff I just came back to me when you're
like I can't do I can't eat pizza I'm
lactose in the last like three years
I've developed a lactose issue you don't
think I've had 87 000 milkshakes prior
to that I bet you have yeah I have okay
yeah am I wrong you don't think I can
have a lactose-free milkshake every time
you have a every time you have a you
don't think I could make a milkshake
with lactose free almond milk or
whatever you don't think I could do that
oh no
very much this is very sincere I have
not had a milkshake since I've developed
my lactic but that issue has developed
over the last few years you'd remember
that if you would listen to me anytime
I've told you about it every time I've
told you about it
yeah but you are but no no lactose
intolerant is basically your stomach
gets upset and you [__] I get an allergy
like in my throat my throat and her ears
start to itch and then I'll
it shows point a lot of people I know
will take their lactose pill just to
have ice cream or pizza that's true too
but I don't have the same I will fall on
the sword for a milkshake not for root
beer float Thank you Pam yeah look I'm
not I'm not not acknowledging the
Behemoth that is the milkshake and I
didn't even say that I don't like
milkshakes I do but I think there are
cons to them and I also think that the
root beer float to me is more refreshing
it quenches thirst while it's creamy and
I don't have it as often so when I have
it I'm always more excited about it and
I and I had to imagine that that feeling
is how a lot of people feel
I guess but in this country like people
like thick they like Megan the stallion
so the milkshake might be a little bit
thicker well yeah but again
you gotta wait 15 minutes to have it
I'll tell you what your root beer
float's never done ain't brought nobody
to the yard and we all know that I was
hoping that you wouldn't go there well
like pimp keep playing the video he
clearly wanted me to show I didn't see
that oh that's what that was
yeah have you ever seen a woman that hot
singing about a root beer float
ever my Ruby float brings the girls to
the yard please please if you went out
on a date and bought a woman a root beer
float or drink could you imagine let's
just talk you went on a date
root beer float in front of her if she
didn't spit on me and walk out I would
have no respect but they're in identical
categories what are you talking about no
they are not no they are not no
milkshake a drink I drink cute a drink
fun a drink
a root beer float I would be looking for
the pens peeking out of the person's
pants it's it's old people they're both
desserts base with on ice cream served
in glasses I didn't even know it said
that root beer floats Are For Old Men
milkshakes for the win it's not my fault
that's that this woman
didn't come around to root be afloats it
doesn't know about that a root beer
float is just less of what makes a
milkshake good you're always left
wanting more ice cream milkshake all day
root beer floors like using cough syrup
on ice cream thank you Kenny
milkshakes are great
huh
did we set off the alarm I don't know no
earlier actually milkshakes are great if
you love the worm Embrace of phlegm and
have temporary Kermit voice that's what
I'm talking about yeah
before it was a false alarm he came on
set to false I think they're testing the
system or something when's the last time
you did a fire drill
dude I went off at my hotel this weekend
really yeah the last time I was in
Boston my this weekend was rescheduled
because all the fire alarms in Boston
went off on the same night wait a minute
you think it's you
I want to talk to you about diet and
therefore I want to talk to you about
Noom I am somebody who was zigzagged
about between many different diets and
diet Trends and things like that over
the years I've made some drastic changes
very suddenly uh trying to find the
right fit and I love Noom why because
Noom is the first psychology based
approach I've ever experienced or
discovered when it comes to food in your
eating habits it's it's
a program that helps you understand the
science behind your eating choices and
why you have cravings for people out
there that have used eating coaches uh
for people out there that have tried
again these fad diets uh you know it's
it's they're tough things and they often
don't stick why because it's not helping
you understand the food you're eating
and why you are eating it uh here's
another thing that you really should put
a pin in and and keep yours open for
first time numerous was an average of 15
pounds after being active in the program
for 16 weeks and 95 percent of customers
say Noom is a good long-term solution it
helped me understand food better and it
may understand my eating better I like
Noom so stop chasing those Health Trends
and build sustainable healthy habits
with nooms psychology-based approach
sign up for your trial today at noon.com
taste bud that's n-o-m.com taste bud and
sign up for your trial today also check
out new rooms first ever book the new
mindset a deep dive into the psychology
of behavior change available to buy
wherever books are sold
uh all right milkshakes are all right we
did that lime milkshake that's another
great point
you can have a milkshake you can have a
milkshake with a with a with a tart
flavor to it like you can you can have
like a lemon like uh or citrusy
milkshake type of thing you can't root
beer float root beer floats always an
option as a kid homemade I blame low
motivation fair enough
milkshakes come in so many different
flavors like Joe's personality this
debate isn't even fair
and milk yeah that's disgusting no no
I've never even never never even
yeah
I swear to get that we I know everyone
did it when I was little
do we know what's going on this is
insane
this is insane we don't even know what's
going on is this
this is insane all right one fact about
both of these is they were used as
vehicles for alcohol when they were
invented something about the program you
could Spike both of them oh that's the
other thing the bourbon milkshakes
But but so a bourbon milkshake is a
thing a spiked root beer float is not a
thing why not of course it's not a thing
I hate when you make those yeah where
where have you when have you ever gone
to a bar and seen it let off with the
sentence that it used to be used it used
to be places still places still serve
spiked milkshakes They don't serve Spike
root beer floats it's not a Joe you're
you're stupid I'm not not stupid you
don't think any Blazers to spike through
people any I'm sure there's one or two
places on planet Earth that do it so yes
I'm saying on average I'm staying on
average let's talk numbers here let's
talk numbers here you know that there's
way more chance of finding a spiked
milkshake you know that I feel refreshed
after a root be afloat oh get the F not
because because it is more of like an
actual drink ice cream you're just
eating just softened cream at the end of
it it doesn't quench a thirst two boxes
for me it feels like a dessert but then
at the end of it I feel like that last
sip is so good that last sip of the last
piece of root beer and the last melted
ice cream but it's also a little more
liquidy cold consistency it's a beverage
a milkshake is like is beverage adjacent
it's not really a beverage all right you
know what I'm gonna do you know what I'm
gonna do okay go do something after we
wrap today we can't drink a root beer
flow go do something watch me watch me
you know what I do after I drink a
milkshake take a [__] I have sex baby no
you don't because it's a link no you
don't thing to do no you don't ever stop
everybody we get two straws in that
strawberry shake like lovers uh
[Music]
mix that
yeah yeah it's got to be someone someone
puts a jack put some auto-tune on that
[__]
your fan that makes all this
sort of tone it flip it smack it up flip
it rub it down
yeah you if you have I think now you
will not have sex again
I'll always have sex I don't know not
for people who heard that not from
people who that's disgusting
nobody else bloats themselves and nobody
else through a milkshake you don't have
to drink the whole thing by the way you
animal you can leave some you're allowed
to leave some food on the table do you
know that did you know you're allowed to
not eat all of it yeah I do Joe but you
just said after you've finished one you
go have sex yeah I'm saying I'm talking
about that maybe I don't drink the
little canister that comes with so maybe
I drink so you really want to say I'll
tell you what I do after I have a few
sips of milkshake oh please oh please
I'll tell you what I'm gonna do after we
wrap today you're gonna cushion so I can
hear all you talked out of your ass
you're gonna walk out of here and
everything you say to everyone is always
like there's no place on Earth no one
ever said this no one ever did that it's
empire doesn't it just go let's go it's
about that time let's go to the phones
officially let's go to the photos
officially
John Wolfe says also one is a delicate
balance of sweet buddy bubbly and Rich
ice cream the other feels like a cement
mixer dumped into the payload into your
guts I love you John Wolf milkshakes a
thousand percent more accessible
multi-flavored brings all the boys to my
yard more accessible is actually a point
uh that I was making in a positive a
positive point about the root beer float
floats it's more of a treat because you
don't have it as often
floats are the mix of two things that
don't even live in the same neighbor are
they not even the same state they
shouldn't be friends the adults here
choosing root beer float are the same
people who refer to high school as the
best time
although I don't think that but sure
milkshake all day if you give Joe root
beer float we got a boycott
I already know Joe's going to defend
root beer float by saying it's classic
or some [__] but no one has drank a
root beer float since the Carter
Administration it's all not true that's
what I'm saying it's like it is true Sal
I love whatever he agrees with you you
go that's how you know it's true and
then when they agree with me you go this
is all not true root beer floats are not
a thing anywhere unless you make it at
home you saw it in one restaurant in the
last decade and you're saying therefore
places carry it you can get it any diner
you can go get it at any time in your
dessert shop you can get it at home off
menu you can't make a milkshake at home
nobody's nobody's at home with no one
has that special machine
you don't need a special you're at home
[__] beating with your hands mixed
milkshakes he's a blender to make a milk
nobody at home is making milkshakes
people at home you poor glasses go buy
ice cream in it maybe a little bit
you're off to the races in two seconds
root beer floater with trash thinks his
class
ordering a root beer float something a
deadbeat dad orders for their forgotten
about child in the hopes that they won't
forget about the terrible thing they've
done I
every week the thing that people don't
like they all respond to it in the same
exact way even though it not it doesn't
really track you're just saying that
because you're gonna lose well I'm
clearly gonna lose uh I think the winner
is the the one that we both left root
beer floats are the reason a w is
America's oldest restaurant chain
last week in Canada actually yes yes
that's every time we do the JFL Montreal
I go to the a w in the food court of
that mall because I'm like what a
special treat they have the A and W boys
what do you have there
I don't get a root beer float no no a
signature drink I don't know 100 years I
don't I didn't even know they had that
there honestly I get the I get it I get
fast food I get like a burger and fries
and [__] you didn't know that a w had a
root beer float I swear to God I never
even lost the same thing if you don't
even know that they basically one of the
founders like one of the the biggest
Advocates and and the biggest sources of
Ruben flows you didn't even know that
they served that but you're yelling out
loud at the top of your lungs yeah sorry
sorry I didn't think to look for the
item I've never seen on a menu ever at
the one fast food place I visit every
five years because it's practically
extinct what does it matter if it's on a
menu do you hear people the arguments
coming out of this message
you put it no no
you sell yeah you're I'm speaking to
your point about me not seeing it on the
a w menu and then you say what's it
matter if it's on a menu I'm not
speaking about my preference those
points can coexist
then why are you double talking to me
you're assuming that's on no menus yet
you didn't know the most famous menu of
all that you go to no what I said was I
wouldn't even think to look for it on
that menu because I've never seen it on
a goddamn menu sure that's what I'm
saying okay and I don't like it so I
doubly wouldn't look for it on that menu
that's what I said anyway that's what I
said Thank You V thank you man the whole
team's with me today buddy all those
teams can agree that they like
milkshakes over Ruby it floats it
doesn't change anything they're also
agreeing with all these
you're talking you're talking real
backwards today you're doing this is
going to be a classic episode because
it's your classic arguments you're only
speaking absolutes and it it just
immediately it loses the Integrity of
the argument because it's no Nuance what
are you talking about what your drink
sucks my drink is awesome what else is
there to do to argue well they're never
this no one's ever done this you'd never
find this you were able to name one
place that you were at two days ago that
had a root beer float on the menu no Joe
can I name a specific thing you said
diners I'll say diners too
you're a bad [__] crazy pull up a menu
for here 15 15 best places for rupiah
floats in Manhattan Bond Street Lounge
sorry Van lewen Ice Cream Shop one of
the best shots 16 Handles one of the
biggest shops there are Jacob's pickles
I just said they were Michael J fox or
Paul listen this name drop well I did I
mean
oh nice restaurants Earl's beer and
cheese shop okay that's another one
these places are awesome
right your
[__] has them oh how did I not no no
that's a huge company bro I don't so now
we just named 15 places easily in
Manhattan some of them a major change
hold on a second the word shake hold on
a second and now it's no who cares hold
on a second you did not name 15 places
easily you needed a guide that was
curated because people that are looking
for this extinct drink need a guide to
tell them where to find the goddamn
thing
if you Google where to find the best
milkshakes in New York City won't come
up because people know what milkshakes
audio dick article will still come up
right it didn't require an article but
his point is that the reason that
article exists
every time I debunk anything you
so they're more special to me milkshake
can get everywhere rupia floats are not
as well
you said the article was made because
people need to go there because they
don't know where to find stand by that
okay so that would mean that milkshake
shouldn't have an article like that
because everyone knows where to get
milkshakes no that's not true right so
that debunks your [__] claims all
right they're not mutual excuses
in places seven of them are National
chains and and all of a sudden
which of those seven were National
chains [__] by the way let's just talk
about shakes
Shake Shack Shake Shack has rupia floats
oh really yeah you know why because they
gotta get rid of the [__] vanilla ice
cream nobody wants and they gotta add
something to them
that's strong that's strong dude they
don't move vanilla shakes they need it
to get rid of the vanilla let's go to
the boat
we know when your argument's a horse
[__] right no they're not horseshit the
fact you can't even speaking Shake Shack
has a root be afloat the place that's
most known for shakes Shake Shack you
don't know where you can get a ruby
upload Shake Shack has them the place
known for shakes okay okay
I'd like to see a current Shake Shack
menu from The Shake Shack website Let It
Go Joe just when there's a fact just
[__] believe the fact I want to see
it oh my God I want to see it oh my God
oh my God then let's roll you're
untenable if it's so oh my God then
let's look it just listed it let's look
I've been to a lot of places where they
say they have a certain thing and you go
and they don't have it anymore let's
just look let's just look let's just
look are you saying that you don't think
any Shake Shacks carry rupiah
current menu here's the menu go down
right there pimp there's a drink thing
see it on the bottom drinks lemonade
lemonade lemonade lemonade I mean beer
okay I wonder what's gonna come with
that so now go to ice cream pimp
shake shake oh please there it is right
please please right there root beer
would have felt so good you know you
should do that you felt so good yeah but
it doesn't it doesn't smell it feels bad
right because you're wrong
you should be filled with negativity I
don't care I'm telling you should feel
bad Teflon Don no all you do all you're
doing is losing the Integrity of your
arguments no I'm not I'm gonna win the
battle because you're you're refusing
anything else you're just saying no
you're like trumping you're like Donald
Trump yeah what are you doing okay
well then he lost and now he's in jail
okay then I'll go to jail over my
milkshake arguments this is a bad this
is a bad argument from you today no it
wasn't I believe it is can we pick from
the bottom of my heart I believe it was
bad can we pick our winner yep give it
to the tweet from the person that made
us laugh that that was good
but we gotta we gotta shout shout them
out though what's the cheer choosing
root beer flow simply refer to high
school is the best time of their lives
it's Sam Loop follow Sam thank you Sam
all right pimp
I mean we know milkshake's gonna win
before we started but let's see what I
hope I pull more than 25.
that's what you want to do I still love
you buddy I love you too
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to the mic I'm talking